l'info est bien passé sur les panneaux
municipaux quant aux bus lui-même il est
suffisamment voyant pour ne pas le rater
ici ceux qui désirent faire les
vendanges peuvent donc déposer leur
candidature et ensuite en fonction des
candidats qu'on aura reçues sur les
différentes villes c'est nous qui dès la
semaine prochaine allons nous mettre en
contact avec les domaines viticoles
qu'on connaît ou qu'on ne connaît pas
pour leur dire pour leur proposer les
différents candidats qu'on a reçues
durant notre présence nous n'avons pas
rencontré de candidats aux vendanges
mais quelques-uns se sont présentés dans
la matinée
en revanche ces deux femmes qui
travaillent dans un domaine viticole
sont venus dans l'espoir de recruter des
vendangeurs a priori en dépit des
initiatives comme ce bus de l'emploi le
problème de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qui ne s'arrange pas si les explications
de ce phénomène sont nombreuses il
semble tout de même que les viticulteurs
qui font un effort sur l'accueil ont
moins de mal à constituer leurs troupes
globalement on n'a pas trop de mal à
recruter on a une équipe soudée moi j'en
loge une quinzaine par an on aurait tout
le monde le midi à class'croute le matin
il ya une pole et une belle fête à la
fin voilà bon j'ai d'autres collègues
qui font que moi je suis pas tout seul
heureusement d'ailleurs
mais ces gens là quand les questions ils
ont quand même moins de problèmes pour
pour recruter il vendu fuller ne fait
pas appel aux prestataires de services
qui ont fleuri dans le vignoble ces
dernières années s'ils y avaient recours
il a fait le calcul
ces vendanges lui coûterait 16 mille
euros de plus c'est un choix économique
c ou une envie de s'embêter on économise
16000 euros passe un bon moment que les
gens mais on a un petit peu mais c'est
un petit peu compliqué ou alors ma foi
on est dans le confort on a les moyens
on fait appel à un prestataire
demain le bus de l'emploi sera à beaune
le matin et chagny l'après midi